unexpressed emotions will never die
they are buried alive and will come
forth later in uglier ways
before you diagnose yourself with
depression or low self-esteem
first make sure that you are not in fact
just surrounded by
if youth knew
if age could
most people do not really want freedom
because freedom involves responsibility
and most people are frightened of
responsibility
one day in retrospect
the years of struggle will strike you as
the most beautiful
words have a magical power
they can bring either the greatest
happiness
or deepest despair
a father's death is the most important
event
the more heartbreaking and poignant loss
in a man's life
[Music]
we are never so defenseless against
suffering as when we love
out of your vulnerabilities
will come your strength
the only person with whom you have to
compare ourselves
is that you in the past
and the only person better you should be
this is who you are now
how bold one gets
when one is sure of being loved
thought is action in rehearsal
in the small matters trust the mind
in the large ones the heart
the scope of one's personality is
defined by the magnitude of that problem
which is capable of driving a person
out of his wits
[Music]
the first indication of stupidity
is a complete lack of shame
we chose not randomly each other
we meet only those who already exists in
our subconscious
friendship is an art of keeping distance
while love is an art of intimacy
who lacks sex
speaks about sex
hungry talks about food
a person who has no money
about money
and our oligarchs and bankers
talk about morality
we enter the world with loneliness
and lonely leave it
being entirely honest with oneself is a
good exercise
[Music]
love and work
work and love
that's all there is
without love
we fall ill
maturity is the ability to postpone
gratification
all family life is organized around the
most damaged person in it
history is just new people making old
mistakes
the only shame in masturbation
is the shame of not doing it well
everyone owes nature a death
when one does not have what one wants
one must want
what one has
experience teaches us that the world is
not a nursery
which quote did you like the most
share your opinion in the comments one
day you will regret that you did not
hear these quotes earlier do not lose
the opportunity watch our next video
[Music]